dr.  tempête nous vous avons donné six ans et des
millions de dollars et vous ne nous avez
rien donné ce qui est différent maintenant Reed
Richards envoie par e-mail des réponses à des questions que nous
ne savons même pas vous poser c'est notre
chance d'en savoir plus sur notre planète
et peut-être même de sauver Je te veux  pour rencontrer
ma fille poursuivre en justice tu veux être célèbre
je veux juste que mon travail fasse une différence
John Green ce mec ne prend pas bien les
commandes ouais surtout quand les gens disent que
je ne prends pas bien les commandes je laisse
ces blouses donner  vous n'importe quelle merde je eh bien
si je sais je sais qui appeler le muscle je
dois dire que c'est amusant de vous avoir ici bon
mm-hmm
ce que vous avez créé ici est incroyable
vous les gars vous êtes sûrs que vous êtes dans la meilleure forme
pour faire ça oh  ouais nous sommes bons, ils
viennent de craquer sur les voyages interdimensionnels tout
ce que je veux savoir, c'est où sont mes enfants
pour AB survivre tous présentent
des conditions physiques uniques
je veux juste réparer mes amis je ne peux pas résoudre ce problème,
vous devriez utiliser ces pouvoirs pour aider les
gens
vous ouvrez le  porte tu ne sais pas comment
te fermer  je ne sais rien de
ce qui se passe
ce qu'il vient
si tu veux l'arrêter
ça va prendre tout ce que tu as
combien de temps jusqu'à ce qu'il soit dans deux minutes
peut être un peu c'est
toi